con nuestra segunda invitada del día
vamos a hablar de la situación política
y social en el reino unido donde el
próximo 5 de septiembre se va a conocer
al sucesor de boris johnson como primer
ministro de reino unido que saldrá de
las votaciones internas del partido
conservador británico
está previsto que la titular de
exteriores el strauss o su rival en las
primarias el ex ministro de economía
crisis una que tome formalmente entonces
la posición de la jefatura de gobierno
este 6 de septiembre según las más
recientes encuestas atrás se cuenta con
la ventaja para así ser la próxima líder
tory y heredar el despacho oficial de
downing street esta inestabilidad
política británica inició cuando el
escándalo del pari gate inició también
cuando salieron a la luz estas fiestas
relacionadas en la oficina del premier
británico durante los confinamientos por
la pandemia que terminaron con la
renuncia de boris johnson saludamos
entonces en este momento a nuestra
segunda invitada del día ella es a
carolinas acató
candidata a una phd en relaciones
internacionales de la universidad en
sant andrews esto en reino unido-
graciascarolina por estar con nosotros
en derecho americano france24
hola raúl buenas tardes muchas gracias
por invitación buenas buenos días en un
call obvia así es empezamos entonces
hablando porque las bases del partido
conservador se inclinan por la tradición
de atrás ante la tecnocracia de su nac
es una buena pregunta
las encuestas le dan una amplia ventaja
a listas por sobre por sobre ríos y
zonas que como bien mencionaste fue
hasta seguro bueno hasta hace muy
poquito el eligieron el equivalente a lo
que sería el ministro de finanzas aquí
en el reino unido fue también el
responsable de implementar el esquema de
fondos durante durante la cuarentena y
el confinamiento por el cob y 19 que
permitió que muchos empleados y muchos
pequeños negocios hubieran
pudieran tener un ingreso en épocas de
negocios cerrados y de confinamiento
forzados por el otro lado lynch tras lo
que lo que tienen en su haber es ser la
responsable de las relaciones exteriores
del reino unido en los últimos años y si
bien ella como postura personal votó a
favor de mantenerse dentro de la unión
europea durante el break si bien ha
negociado el protocolo con irlanda del
norte que es uno de los temas más
álgidos desde la relación
entre irlanda del norte y la república
de irlanda luego de la salida de reino
unido de la unión europea entonces ambos
tienen estas ganancias en saber sobre
las cuales están haciendo campaña pero a
su vez ambos tienen ciertas experiencias
o ciertos puntos negativos que les
pueden jugar en contra regis una casta
hace algunos pocos meses se ha visto
envuelta en un escándalo por el estatus
impositivo de su mujer que también es
una es una persona de gran fortuna
en la india pero que no está domiciliada
en reino unido por para temas
impositivos quizás eso puede ser que la
haya jugado en contra ahora en esta
carrera por por de premiar fin por por
dirigirla el gobierno del reino unido a
los próximos años claro que la orina
también le quiero preguntar cómo está la
situación de los tories en la sociedad
británica en medio de múltiples crisis y
múltiples escándalos como también los
acabas de señalar
cómo está la situación de los tories si
nos permitimos a los números de
diciembre de 2019 han ganado la elección
general con una columna margen de
diferencia que no se veía más de 40 años
en 1909 por lo tanto en términos de
representantes en el gobierno ha siguen
estando muy fuertes y creo que ninguno
de los dos candidatos actuales ha dicho
que va a volver a llamar a elecciones
generales por lo que hasta esperable
mente hasta 2025 van a mantener una
mayoría importante
en la cámara de los comunes es su cámara
de representantes
distintos quizás en cuanto a términos de
sociedad y de las preferencias de la
gente probablemente ese es un gobierno
que se ha visto ha desgastado con estos
escándalos durante durante la pandemia
al confinamiento y ahora ha sumado un
elevado costo de vida esto ya estaba
viendo que se espera o se proyecta una
inflación anual del 18% que son números
no no vistos en el reino unido durante
décadas y un costo vía creciente el
aumento en los precios de la energía
como consecuencia también de las
sanciones a rusia con la invasión a
ucrania se lleva acumulando una
sumatoria de problemáticas y de malestar
social que el próximo muy probablemente
en la próxima primer ministro tenga que
asumir y que por el momento están
golpeando al partido conservador y que
de no ser resueltas en el corto plazo
van a seguir dañando su imagen y su
popularidad a futuro pero hoy en día
tienen más frente una amplia mayoría de
esas la vall ya lo decías muy bien en
carolina porque sin duda la energía es
uno de los temas principales
precisamente hoy también como lo
estábamos conversando se conoció que
regulador vital energía bien hará un
brusco aumento en todos los costos para
los consumidores de reino unido no un
alza del 80 por ciento frente al límite
actual como el tema de la energía como
el tema digamos también del manejo de la
guerra ucrania de este apoyo británico a
la del ucraniano esto también como
avivan a la crisis y cómo se vive esto
en el en el reino unido porque pues
también obviamente afectar
considerablemente los bolsillos de todos
los hogares británicos
y se vive con mucho malestar aquí los
aumentos salariales anuales suelen ser
alrededor del 23 por ciento 5% por lo
tanto este año se espera que no equipare
en la inflación que es algo que si bien
ocurriendo y sumado a aumentos de
energía como bien decías que pueden
llegar al 80 por ciento y estamos ya muy
próximos al invierno la verdad que es un
problema es un problema para la gran
cantidad de hogares no solamente de
clase trabajadora pero también de clase
media y va a ser un tema central la
inflación y el aumento de los precios la
energía para mí van a ser los dos temas
centrales
que le toque a la primer ministro o al
primer ministro en los próximos meses
sin lugar a dudas junto con la evolución
de la guerra en ucrania y el reino
unido- tengan en entrenar tropas y
apoyar el conflicto pero también en
hacer frente a diversificarse en la
energía o ser autosuficientes en energía
tanto tanto rich ricci como liz y ambos
candidatos que están dentro de sus
plataformas de gobierno como ser
autosuficientes en energía en los
próximos 30 años para no tener de vuelta
a este tipo de
consecuentes días luego de tomar
acciones o sanciones económicas en el
contexto de una invasión pondremos en
sus planes
de moss en eso que acabas de mencionar
es carolina precisamente los retos
principales del nuevo primer ministro
quien asuma el próximo 6 de septiembre
para mí fue principalmente es poner un
freno a la inflación que son números
inflacionarios que quizás para con
argentina para nosotros no es tan alto
pero para países europeos ciertamente
son con grandes cambios sobre todo
porque los salarios no no están
programados que aumenten a ese nivel
entonces la gente pierde poder
adquisitivo pero también hay una gran un
gran sector de la población
especialmente los jubilados y
pensionados que están enfrentando
disyuntivas entre alimentarse de manera
correcta o pensar si pueden calentar su
casa en el invierno luego aleix
realmente un impacto importante
este va a ser el eje central yo creo que
cualquiera de las dos nuevas
administraciones
controlar la inflación
ambos son propuestos para controlar un
poco la inflación son recortes en los
impuestos por lo menos en el corto plazo
ampliando estos fondos que se habían
preparado para hacerle frente a la
crisis del cob y para pagar el fondo
recortar impuestos brazo es aumentar el
impuesto a las grandes fortunas pero
incentivar el emprendedurismo incentivar
la inversión en los acuerdos comerciales
con terceros países ella de relanzar el
reino unido luego del break si también
que por el momento queda un poco trunca
con la pandemia de ahora con la guerra
de ucrania y controlar el creciente
costo de vida que claramente está siendo
un problema cada vez mayor para para el
británico de clase media y clase
trabajadora